they're making lists that's the focus of
tonight's angle
we don't trust the biden administration
to protect our civil liberties period
they abuse their power on covid they
abuse their power in the way they
handled the january 6 situation and they
trash our country's history every chance
they get
after 13 months of president biden
americans have every reason to be
suspicious of anything they do that
involves collecting information about
americans i'm talking about lists
databases or surveillance of anything
including your health records or social
media history
let's face it they treat half of the
country as if they're the mortal enemy
a threat to be controlled not a
constituency to be served
now when the school crt and sexual
assault issues bubbled up in the u.s
democrats finally found themselves on
the defensive
and then
biden's attorney general merrick garland
he swooped in to flex the power of the
federal law enforcement
his words at the time were meant to
intimidate and scare parents
if you're upset and angry at the
direction your school board is taking
and you show up and you speak your mind
as is your constitutional right by the
way
now you have to be worried about being
caught up in some bogus domestic terror
dragnet
and rather than treat january 6 as a
protest that got way out of hand with
some criminal elements no doubt the bind
administration and their media cronies
insisted on claiming that it was an
insurrection and treating everyone who
supported president trump as a traitor
not even during the civil war
did insurrectionists breach
the capital of the united states of
america
dates that occupy
not only a place on our calendars
but a place
in our collective memory
december 7th 1941
september 11
2001
and january 6
2021. it borders on sedition
here's how the biden team looks at the
world
they believe that most people who
support the gop are dangerous they're
dangerous elements that need to be
policed and watched
now enter the extremism review that
generals austin and millie undertook of
the armed forces after january 6th
so rather than focusing sharply on real
problems they use vague language to
essentially smear huge swaths of the
american public and the military
now in a sense they hung out a
conservatives need not apply sign of the
pentagon
now who knows what files are amassing on
soldiers airmen and marines who they
deem to be potential problems
now maybe they posted pro-trump stuff or
photos from trump rallies on social
media who knows
but which group has been subject you
think to more scrutiny under austin
our own troops
or the nearly 85 000 afghan refugees
they airlifted to the united states well
i think we know the answer to that
question
and presidential wannabe pete
butterjudge he feels where the winds are
blowing in his party and he wants to get
in on the action
as transportation secretary he's
planning to blanket america's roads with
more surveillance cameras billions and
billions of dollars worth supposedly
it's all to cut down on traffic deaths
you know he is a humanitarian
but of course what they really want is
fewer cars and fewer car owners
they want to make it so expensive so
cumbersome to drive and own a vehicle
that only the truly responsible elites
can do so
now and it gets worse and worse
which brings us to the huge story we
brought you last night courtesy of our
friends at the washington free beacon
and republican congressman that the u.s
government is storing just under 1
billion gun purchase files and
digitizing them
presumably for searchability down the
road
now biden's atf and a letter to our next
guest insist that such record keeping
was approved by congress including the
process of digitization
during 2021 they collected data on 54
million gun owners but they waved away
any concern of nefarious intent writing
the sole purpose of these systems is to
trace firearms used in crimes
which is a valuable gun intelligence
tool used in thousands of investigations
by atf and our local state and federal
law enforcement partners
in other words
because of all the good faith they've
shown their fellow americans we're just
supposed to take them at their word this
is all for benign purposes this massive
log of gun purchases it's not a
significant leap toward the ultimate
goal of a national gun registry
sorry
but they do not deserve the benefit of
the doubt
of course we know that all the people
with the power of the democrat party
hate guns and would love nothing more to
confiscate as many as possible under
whatever pretext the supreme court would
allow them to do so
don't take my word for it take theirs
the second amendment from the day it was
passed
limited the type of people could own a
gun and what type of weapon you could
own where there is room under the law
for the president's policies to be
pursued then i i think the president is
entitled to pursue them gun owners out
there who say well obama administration
means they're going to come for my guns
bingo you're right if you have an
assault weapon
now academics also have been working on
many different legal theories to
effectively ban guns in the united
states
they invoke the fight against
skyrocketing gun violence
as if crimes are committed by the guns
themselves and not the revolving door of
criminals that rampage through america
courtesy of left-wing d.a.s
now democrat mayors they don't give a
rip about crime if they did they
wouldn't be empowering the blm crowd at
the expense of the public safety
your second amendment rights i hate to
break it to you mean nothing to them
they stop church attendance protected by
the first amendment over a pandemic
you don't think they'd try to stop gun
ownership protected by the second
amendment over an epidemic of violence
gun violence in this country is an
epidemic it's an epidemic for god's sake
and it has to stop
biden himself and his supporters in the
media frequently bemoan
the growing lack of public trust in
government it's growing across party
lines
but the pride administration they don't
have anyone to blame except themselves
because along the way as i've
demonstrated tonight they've shown so
much bad faith in so many different
contexts from our intel agencies to the
public health sector to law enforcement
and even the previously innocuous
department of transportation
and now they've gone so far as to cast
traditionally minded americans as public
enemy number
one republicans in congress especially
when they take back power
they need to exercise strict oversight
over every aspect of this biden team
and they need to prohibit and defund
every action and every policy that
undermines our basic constitutional
rights there are a lot of such actions
and policies and that's the angle